extreme heat is broiling a large part of
the nation this holiday weekend
and rough weather could later strike
parts of the south hurricane elsa is
rapidly moving towards jamaica after
battering barbados and other islands in
the eastern caribbean
it could soon turn to the southeast u.s
by tuesday
at the same time a deadly heat dome
stays parked in the pacific northwest
and extends eastward
meteorologist jeff beridelli doing some
multitasking at its finest tracking all
of that weather jeff good morning
good morning dana good morning everyone
so we're going to start that
multitasking right now with elsa and
elsa
you know it's a very rare hurricane in
fact it's almost unheard of to have a
hurricane
develop this early in the season and
that far east now the good news is it's
moving fast and it's a fairly
weak hurricane with winds right around
75 miles an hour
once it moves over cubit will weaken
probably a little bit more and then
bring some rain and wind to south
florida unfortunately
on monday right now the center of the
cone looks to be right over the fort
myers tampa area could see
five to ten inches of rain maybe some
places a little more
and some storm surge of flooding is
going to be a problem there as we head
into tuesday and wednesday
across the rest of the country for your
fourth of july holiday looking pretty
good there'll be some showers in the
northeast
a little bit on the cool side hot in
minneapolis at 94 degrees it is bone dry
in the west we are already in record
territory now almost
all of the west covered in drought 60
percent extreme doubt
drought fires to the southwest there are
fires starting along the west coast and
especially
in canada you know during and i spelt
forest wrong
forest fire don't know i didn't know i
got it right i got it right
not enough coffee this morning
firestorms in canada sparked
700 000 lightning strikes
so fires causing their own weather
sparking fires in canada so i want to
leave you with this
look at the time of year when humans
start the most fires there's january
july and december
look at that huge spike on july 4th so
folks be careful do not take chances way
too dry in the west firestorms in the
forest so you got it
you got it all right thank you very much